[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir et bienvenue
dans ce sport première spéciale en
hommage à camille alexandre ce soir je
serai en compagnie de deux journalistes
sportifs manière la rade
bonsoir bonsoir et patric jean guy tôt
ensemble nous reviendrons sur quelques
temps forts de la carrière de camille
alexandre sur les antennes de martinique
1ère et pour l' hommage à cette icône du
sport martiniquais nous reviendrons avec
quelques invités du monde sportif et
bien sûr avec nous sur le plateau alfred
de fortis président du comité origine un
cycliste de martinique de squales fred
bonsoir nous recevrons également le
secrétaire général de la ligue de
football de la martinique jean claude
larue bonsoir nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir malgré une bouton qui est
présidente de la ligue de twirling bâton
pour soi et merci encore voir ça et
aussi le régatier d'excellence jean
trudeau qui est avec nos est toujours
sur les hommes jean trudeau bonsoir et
si vous voyez des manuels on va
commencer par une cité chère aux yeux de
camille s'agit du football qu'il a bien
fait pendant plus de 40 ans avec ses
commenté camille alexandre le football
c'est l'histoire d'une grande passion
avant d'être avant d'être journaliste
sportif il aimait jouer au foot à
arbitrer les matchs les commenter tout
au long de sa carrière
le football est restée au coeur de sa
profession il assurait tous les directs
il avait toujours un invité fonction son
plateau au tout sur cette grande
histoire d'amour avec le football un
reportage de kelly babou
[Applaudissements]
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir bonsoir à
tous et merci de votre attention
18h15 l'heure du magazine sportif de
martinique 1ère 40 ans de service car un
temps des missions de direct de
commentaires 40 ans et toujours la même
passion intacte pour les sports donc
j'avais quel voyage la salle est celle
pas mais avec une histoire d'amour
particulière pour le football c'est une
passion qui te j'aime bien ce sacerdoce
comme j'étais petit c'est ce que vous
vouliez faire journalistes cette journée
du journalisme et surtout rallye sportif
est pas un club un joueur une
compétition une anecdote ne lui
résistait camille alexandre c'était une
véritable encyclopédie vivante on
aperçoit a donné l'une des anciennes
gloires de la scène club de rugby la
pagode équipe du racing à l'époque
d'eiffage pigeard il avait ses mots bien
à lui
le coup de fusil de chasse
saupoudrez qu'on le veuille ou non d'un
humour à la cami alexandre
[Musique]
avec toujours le clin d'oeil aux
familles des joueurs
la fera plaisir à sa maman qui habite à
sainte luce à ses parents il est de
cette leucémie guinot ça fera plaisir à
votre part afin de piloter sans oublier
ses collègues ne sais c'est de mettre à
l'honneur
elles m'ont mariette et phoques qui fait
également les sports et puis les
cameramen qui sont très importants alors
c'est vrai qu'on connaît d'elle blanc on
a daily sans qu'on ait mal ça son point
d'honneur et des les jeunes footballeurs
à sortir de l'ombre
aujourd'hui le vide est gros mais le
constat est sans appel de l'année eh
bien oui camille par ton implication est
ta patience
tu as été le meilleur sportif de ces
quarante dernières années je sévis ou
rfo je continuerai à seville
j'entends et vous confirmer c'est un
passionné de football
oui passionné de football et puis une
très forte personnalité qui ne laissait
pas indifférent
on l'aimait on les met en tout cas ce
qu'on peut retenir c'est ça sa très
grande connaissance de tous les sports
on voit comment sa disparition a été
ressenti au sein du football
martiniquais écouter pour nous ça a été
un choc puisque je vous rappelle qu'on a
vu camille pour la dernière fois donc le
5 février lors de la loterie de la
campagne 10 matinino donc c'était le
premier entraînement de la sélection a
dit long et puis nous avions rendez vous
le lendemain lors d'une conférence de
presse pour présenter donc le nouveau
manager de la sélection ainsi que son
star et puis nous avions pris y aura du
monde ce jour-là on devait se revoir
donc ce samedi pour la conférence de
presse de présentation de la coupe
m mg mutuellement à gaia est d'ailleurs
à cette occasion dans la profité pour
lui rendre hommage
alors parlons de la sélection vous allez
bientôt notamment avoir des rencontres
avec d'autres nations
tout à fait donc il ya deux événements
majeurs à venir
football martiniquais c'est la ligue des
nations de la concacaf à laquelle nous
participerons à compter de septembre
prochain
donc toutes les dates fifa nous aurons
deux matches internationaux dans cette
nouvelle compétition dont le tirage
option aura lieu du 3 au 5 mars à miami
le siège de l'acadien vous parliez
effectivement de la coupe mutuelle mare
gaillard avec notamment le retour de la
guyane c'est quand même une bonne chose
oui une coupe m mg mutuelle mare
gaillard qui offre un nouveau format
puisque cette année nous intègre donc la
guyane donc des phases vocale dans
chaque territoire et une phase
interrégionale du 3 au 8 mais qui va se
dérouler en martinique
merci donc si on peut le voir une coupe
couture elle n'en est rien comment ce
mardi avec notamment le match qui a
opposé le club colonial au golden layan
au stade pierre aliker et le mercredi
donc le rc rivière-pilote qui reçoit en
cas mais le club franciscain vous l'avez
dit un camille était aussi un amoureux
du cyclisme on a tous des souvenirs de
ces commentaires radio en télé pour le
cyclisme mais aussi avec et patrick des
analyses pointues dans les grands
formats notamment fait le cycliste
faisait partie du sport apprécié de
camille alexandre trophée tour de
martinique qui j'en passe depuis 1990 il
a fait vivent toutes ces manifestations
toi radio qu'en télévision et là où
hélitreuille nouveau castres parcours de
bosses camille
[Musique]
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
1990 camille fait vivre tour cycliste de
martinique depuis la ligne d'arrivée un
car régie pour plateau quatre chaises en
plastique et du bagout pour tenir
l'antenne pendant plusieurs heures est
mort vive celui de 92 et déjà des
formules mythique camille alexandre
présentera aussi des défis sportifs
plutôt bon enfant dans le cadre du
téléthon sera plus nombreux on s'amuse
en tout cas l'essentiel c'est de
participer à ce téléthon 2005 retour en
plateau pour le tour cycliste camille en
chef d'orchestre du magazine du tout non
non nous allons donc retrouver tout de
suite allé rosalie cddu est allé rosa
les envois de course cette fois c'est
avec boys modèle ces dernières années
c'est avec son acolyte nickel roi qu'il
présentait le résumé du tour cycliste
pourquoi pousser leurs deux coaches end
c'est parti pour ce que ce matin c'était
du côté du carbet avec depuis 1976
le journaliste aura commenté quarante
années de sport en martinique une
expertise une encyclopédie qui a côtoyé
et marqué plusieurs générations de
sportifs mais gallois pour vos
commentaires tantôt d'installer semaine
bonne soirée à tous merci à tous
alfred de fortis camille titeux fervent
défenseur de la petite reine que toi que
ce que je vais devoir j'ai le coeur
serré pour vous répondre
en tout cas camille a été le défenseur
de notre cyclisme
camille galopant à droite à gauche
rappelez-vous avec sa caméra était
régulier au rendez-vous du cyclisme et
déjà vendredi il m'a manqué le coup de
fil de karni bout les perspectives du
cyclisme pour le week-end camille que
diable lui il n'y a pas suffisamment de
mots pour le qualifier
l'homme sérieux le combattant de sa
caméra le combattant de ces informations
venir prendre les efforts et camille au
rendez vous le disait et a pas si
longtemps le matin très tôt on peut lui
donner rendez-vous à 6 heures du matin
pour une compétition il est présent il
fait son boulot et pam baratin pas de
dégâts et il s'en va il va ailleurs
et moi je dis déjà j'espère il n'y aura
pas de remplaçante camille je sais très
bien que vous l'avez vu faire si votre
boulot vous allez relever ce défi mais
il était unique unique et j'espère
j'espère que de leur île et il va
continuer à nous aider dans le sport
la dernière question vous avez loué une
forte amitié camier vous oui une forte
amitié parce que je connais camille
depuis très longtemps j'ai déjà là
maintenant plus plus de 50 ans de
cyclisme
camille j'ai pas une trentaine d'années
une quarantaine d'années je veux bien
longtemps nous avons lié
une amitié extraordinaire et puis un
combat pour ce sport et je prend la
défense de camille pour dire c'est pas
que le cyclisme il l'avait vu ce cette
passion pour tout le sport pour les
yoles intensité et très souvent grâce à
camille je pense que il ya eu l'élan du
knb battant qui qui qui qui prend de
l'élan
donc pour vous dire que il va nous
manquer et il nous manque déjà
et bien comme vous l'avez dire il était
sur tous les fronts jamais me dire sur
tous les plans d'eau notamment donc avec
la voile traditionnelle
on parlera incontestablement de laguiole
la yole ronde où la voix de camille a
marqué tous les directs de se dire de
cette retransmission du tour des yoles
rondes et d'ailleurs à manuela on ne
peut que compter 18 mois il a commencé
depuis 1989 à commenter les courses de
viol à l'époque que camille était sur le
terrain plus près des violeurs dans les
années 2000 les revenus sur le plateau
de martinique première il a notamment
donc commenter avec jean trudeau ce tour
de martinique des yoles rondes entre
autres tout comme l'année dernière où il
est encore présent en votre compagnie
jean trudeau on retrace justement cette
aventure d'ailleurs avec aurélie treuil
1989 troisième tour de la martinique des
yoles rondes
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir le
service va bon train
robert c'est normal et beaucoup de
pronostic une arrivée très disputée
c'est la yole de françois nissan qui
s'est imposé devant celle du robert et
sait déjà qu ami alexandre et ses
chemises colorées qui font vivre le tour
aux martiniquais qui voit donc endossé
le maillot jaune de rfo un personnage
une discipline est indissociable d'une
histoire qui durera trois décès de
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
première victoire d'étape pour ces
halles un style vestimentaire qui évolue
mais les expressions elles ne bougeront
pas
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
avec un humour bien à lui
à ce prix c'est capital yola à oui oui
c'est respectable italia là pourquoi à
l'aide et des qualités cet esprit
maurice n'aboutit qu'à a présenté et
journal du tour l'arabité cet esprit
d'analysé et commentée tous leurs radios
qu'habiter cet esprit monziols donc à
présenter journal 15 heures et la forêt
du bois habité est détruit et comme vous
ou c'est un bouc d'esprit où ça vous
savez ce même label la balade strasbourg
où norbert mesdames messieurs donc
l'information est donc tombée dix ans
après la formule évolue le journaliste
également du terrain au plateau télévisé
c'est toujours camille qui anime le
débat avec ses anecdotes ne communique
sur l' enveloppe financière mais on a
quand même deux tuyaux
il ya des hommes qui ont des budgets
dépassant les 100 millions
la mémoire vivante du sport en
martinique nous aura fait vivre sa
passion jusqu'au 12 mai déterminer vive
le taux de martinique des yoles rondes
2018 merci pour nous avoir suivis by
[Musique]
allez dd laguiole a perdu un grand
défenseur
tout à fait tout à fait ce mode et
chaussures mais c'est quelqu'un qui a
donné une couleur autour de la matinée
auront mais c'était une complicité qu'il
y avait entre nous pour qu'il fallait
faire un certain nombre de choses pour
que la mode n'est plus approprié cet
événement mais lui donner vraiment la
couleur la martinique et camille a su
trouver les mots et de se trouver des
expressions il a su rassembler les gens
et puis il a su justement au sein de
matinée première se comprendre que c'est
quelque chose d'essentiel et qu'il
fallait vraiment se donner les moyens
médiatiquement de mecs cette
manifestation valeur alors il va nous
manquer pour ce tour 2010 8 to qui déjà
bien en place bientôt qui se prépare qui
se prépare effectivement et nous avions
commencé à travailler sur un certain
nombre de choses aux seynois des dix
premiers avec camille pour donner à
cette manifestation quelque chose de
particulier parce que mon ambition de
passer à la 3d avec quelque chose
d'extraordinaire camille était à fond là
dessus effectivement il va nous manquer
dans la réflexion mais il va falloir
continuer et aller jusqu'au bout pour
lui jean trudeau vous l'avait accompagné
notamment l'année dernière pour robin le
tour 2010 est khamis a été véritablement
quelqu'un qui connaissait un peu cette
discipline comme les autres disciplines
qu'ils connaissaient toutes les
disciplines mais plus particulièrement
les puits avec moi on avait défini
quelque chose qui était assez
particulier il me rappelait souvent le
consultant c'est toi le journaliste et
moi qu'à partir du moment où nous avions
décidé que nous allions faire
différemment c'est à dire amener lier
dans les foyers mais à des gens qui ne
la connaissent pas qui ne savent pas ce
que c'est avec ses parents de cette
particularité ces expositions c'est sa
bonhomie souvent ces petits dérapages
mais l'amitié que jamais parce que c'est
un homme grand professionnel mais un
homme d'une profonde amitié d'une
sincère amitié je suis un peu ému quand
je parle de lui on avait convenu qu'il
fallait pas parler de choses et je la
mets 10 % intéresser les gens mais pas
vraiment alors on avait toujours ce
petit débat mais c'était vraiment ces
dernières années j'ai vécu des grands
moments a commenté le tour de martinique
des yeux ronds avec amis et comme j'ai
dit je le répète le tout ne sera plus
pareil sans camille corot t2 que
retenez-vous côte haut niveau en quelque
sorte de cette belle aventure que vous
avez eue avec camille alexandre je
retiens une expression de rapidement
lorsque nous commente u19 et quand ils
me disaient la vérité elle est déjà
arrivé jeudi camille n'ont pour
l'instant
et alors il avait noté le pour un style
plus chaque fois il me disait pour
l'instant pour l'instant donc ça a duré
cinq minutes
c'est un petit peu notre débat de fait
de route après trois heures de stress
mais il va nous manquer came merci
beaucoup alors la popularité de cali
alexandre a largement débordé des
terrains sportifs hors des compétitions
des personnalités mais aussi des
anonymes ont été touchées par le décès
de camille le 10 février dernier
j'oppose d'écouter quelques réactions
recueillies par kelly babeau et
guillaume précis n'ai qu'à me alexandre
un homme un journaliste un passionné qui
aura marqué des générations de
martiniquais et qui aura laissé sans
aucun doute sa trace
il connaît très très bien c'est un
moment de grâce et a séduit assez polis
et respectueux et puis
du beau ça ça fait du mal quand ils me
voyaient un soap au relais sur le
terrain et tout et puis il était
toujours fonds soient en train de
rigoler avec les pâtisseries sur le
marché du robert le nom de camille est
aussi sur toutes les lèvres apprécie ou
non des tracts et ou pas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il n'a laissé personne
indifférent avec les clients n'en
apparaît aussi que ça a choqué tout le
monde quoi on s'attendait vraiment pas
ce qu'est vraiment la surprise pour leur
aide
la livre face à camille avec son mais ça
fait choper dont les rues du centre
ville de fort-de-france l'ipa son
tiennent à partager les souvenirs
l'image qu'ils retiennent de camille
alexandre des réactions à chaud comme
quand on écrit quelques lignes dans un
livre d'or c'est un gars déterminer qui
aimait bien rigolé aussi un lors de ses
interviews mardi
[Musique]
abel balbo
en belgique aussi hommage kenya
et comment ne pas finir cet hommage
populaire sans évoquer ce qui faisait de
camille alexandre notre camille à nous
c'est quand on faisait des trucs de
cyclisme me disait top top top auto
power flower doute une photo qu'on fait
ça ça m'avait fait camille c'était aussi
le visage de tous les sports même les
moins connus comme le twirling bâton
madame marie vinh bouton bonsoir vous
êtes la présidente
justement du turn in bâton qu'elle
emprunte justement vous gardez de
camille qui a fait découvrir ce sport
finalement martinique
absolument d'abord je voudrais dire que
camille pour moi va laisser l'image d'un
grand témoin martiniquais du sport et
camille c'était un ami à grand frère
beaucoup s'interrogeaient sur la nature
de nos relations il ya si peu de femmes
dirigeantes du monde au niveau du monde
sportif et c'était un conseiller c'est
quelqu'un qui m'avait que m'a beaucoup
accompagné j'ai du mal à parler au passé
de parler de lui au passé et il l'avait
vraiment envie et c'est très rare que
les femmes accèdent à des instances de
décisions et aux ir ce très souvent on a
de la peine à 10 ou de la difficulté à
dire pour le twirling bâton qu'à miami
le thé oolong bâton sur le piédestal où
il est aujourd'hui
et je me rappelle il ya dix ans quand je
suis venu le voir lui apporter un
dossier ben depuis dix ans il nous a
suivis depuis cette année-là nous a
suivis nous a jamais lâchés en parlant
de nos événements sportifs en parlant
aussi de toute l'actualité du curling
bâton il a appris à connaître ce sport
il est entré dans le monde du curling et
c'est ce qui m'a fait voir c'était un
homme intelligent un vrai démocrate et
c'est quelqu'un vraiment qu'ils avaient
l'amour du sport
il nous manque il nous manque à tous
alors il y aura bien sûr un avant et un
après avec l'amiens ac s'en nourrit
qu'elle chante si vous avez commencé
avec lui que vous aimerez poursuivre
nous avons commencé le chantier de la
préparation de la coupe du monde
alors c'est vrai il est un journaliste
un vrai un professionnel et il se tenait
régulièrement informé des avancées du
dossier et s'il ya encore trois semaines
nous en parlions puisque je lui disais
que le championnat qui démarre la
semaine prochaine le championnat
départemental
on commencera à repérer des athlètes qui
pourrait représenter la martinique à la
coupe du monde en 2019
donc il suivait aussi le championnat de
france puisque régulièrement nous avons
la chance d'avoir de bons résultats et
donc ce sont des chantiers qui suivait
régulièrement et il connaissait déjà le
nom des athlètes mais aussi beaucoup
mais un bouton rappelle que vous êtes la
présidente du téléthon en martinique
merci alors nous accueillons sur le
plateau alex voyez vous êtes le
secrétaire général du cros ma merci de
nous rejoindre alors vous représentez un
petit peu tous les sports quel retour
vous avez eu des autres ligues justement
que vous représentez bonsoir à tous la
première chose que je vais dire même si
adresser mes sincères condoléances et
les produits nécessaires vos doléances
du monde sportif à la famille de camille
à la famille de matinée de pognon le
réseau que nous avons c'est à dire que
le com vient de dire madame bhutto cet
ami était celui qui parlait de tous les
sports tous les sportifs que ce soit les
jeunes les pubs les plus anciens et long
des délibérations de du jury de la nuit
des champions
il était celui qui qui qui amenait des
précisions concernant les personnes que
l'on voulait mettre à l'honneur que ce
soit les sportifs ou les coudes les
coups de coeur du bien si beaucoup à
l'ex doyen on rappelle que vous êtes
donc le secrétaire général du cros malo
bien entendu qu'amy aurait souhaité un
qu'on puisse pour suivre l'actualité
justement cette actualité sportive je
vous propose de voir quelques extraits
de temps forts de ce week-end avec un
condensé si c'était un petit frère
les violines du racing club de rivière
pilote et les blanches et rouges du rc
saint-joseph se sont séparés hier soir
sur le score de 3 buts partout au terme
d'un match intense ce qui laisse
présager d'une très belle fin de
championnat
une entame de match ni dire qu'on a fait
on a on appelle existants pour un mi
temps je pense que c'est un excellent
résultat pour et puis on n'a pas de
détermination du mentalité
extraordinaire donc je peux être sûr de
nos prestations
cette année je connais un peu plus
équilibré donc tout le monde veut nous
faire tomber mais on est là on va se
battre jusqu'au bout pour pouvoir gagner
et garder notre image il y avait hier du
volley ball chez les hommes l'espoir de
sainte-luce en verve a fait qu'une
bouchée de l'aiglon jeunes dans les
sports de sainte luce les leaders du
championnat ont fait honneur à leur
public en s'imposant sans difficulté 3
sets à 0
un peu plus tôt les filles de l'espoir
ont eu moins de réussite et se sont
inclinés face à l'éveil 3 sets à 2 les
filles de l'éclair s'incline 3 sets à 0
face au good luck et les filles du ce
match l'emportent face au rayon trois
états chez les hommes le good luck
s'impose 3 sets à 0 face aux pôles en
basket on jouait la 15e journée chez les
femmes la gauloise s'impose face au sc
laventinois 70 à 31 et le golden 'lion'
écrase l'aigle noir cents à 33 chez les
hommes lui sd l'emportent 71 à 62 faso
bbs la gauloise gagne 66 52 face au sc
laventinois le golden laguiole et les
wax s'impose sans surprise les matchs cs
carbet aiglons la reine basket club
l'hirondelle du marin sont annulés good
luck cs vaud qui doit reporter on
connaît les noms des premiers qualifiés
pour les carifta games d'athlétisme
prévus aux bahamas
tamera manette au poids william cadena
au poids et au disque
arnaud du père argot en saut en hauteur
thierry baptiste un saut à la perche
georges jean elie au 5000 m laetitia
bapt et au 100 m haies l'île où martial
et ou laid et mario palun au saut en
longueur
que nos athlètes se rassurent prochain
repêchage prévue le 3 mars au meeting
carifta games vous l'avez encore
remarqué et camille alexandra est un
personnage journaliste qui a marqué de
son empreinte des générations et qui
avait son style bien à lui dans presque
tous ses dires est qu'il aimait passer
de petits messages lâcher quelques
petites blagues
si le sport était son cheval de bataille
le mou était son épée retour sur ces
petits moments d'humour et de bonne
heure avec alibaba dé quoi pour tâche
le sport est il avait surtout le mot la
phrase la petite expression qui savait
nous donner le sourire
est-ce que la relève se prépare déjà ce
qu'est a démandé il faut asseoir et des
achats station alors faire un hommage
sans compilé quelques drôleries et
anecdotes n'en serait pas un digne de ce
nom on devrais je dire plutôt digne de
camille alexandre don camillo bosquet -
un stade louis achille plein comme un
vol vacances la cerise sur le pain tout
le temps sur le boeuf sur le plateau jt
le casa sports champions de forme de
fausse de borce donc lewis âgé de sillac
sommier il était champion et va
présenter les titres du journal de 19
heures l'euro attend samedi après midi
15h avec vos enfants déguisés pour le
candidat ou un pad émission sportive
dimanche à 17h 15 mai dans les journaux
présentés par l'ancienne championne de
badminton
nathalie jos il y aura bien sûr du sport
dans ses innombrables direct d'un camion
d'ailleurs le polo
non non non non non pas de recommander
de deux camions ballet non voiture balai
dont ils voient pas cette enfant vous
êtes de préparer leur bien un petit
rhume mais tout va bien un petit pot je
ne crois pas avoir dit des défis posés
par des et pendant le tour des yoles
techno bien sûr le capitaine éric barret
bonjour capitaine bonjour commandant on
habite rue doit bien dormi avec la
comtesse
il a tout donné il ya une sirène du côté
de la passe de l'écurie il s'agit de
kelly babeau a si je reste sous l'eau
camions je pense que j'avais me noyer
encore sirène sans oublier son
autodérision vous êtes un gros travail
en fait un grand travail
[Rires]
la joie j'ai déniché j'évite d'acheter
et vendre des lunettes
ouais j'ai des lunettes à dolby stéréo
pas de m nous sommes dans les mollets
qui ont fait trembler la carène avec ces
petits mots à lui qu'à me donner cette
autre dimension aux sports et c'est
surtout nous cela qui va terriblement
nous manquer
[Musique]
ben pour cette émission touche à sa fin
je vous propose de faire un petit tour
de table
jean trudeau quelle image vous gardez
justement de camille a beaucoup
d'émotion beaucoup d'émotion je vous
répète c'est un ami sincère et puis ces
petits bobos me moquer parce que je leur
promets appris il m'a appelé m'a dit
beaucoup cas de moussa pour commenter
enfin bon c'est vrai je pas vraiment
m'exprimer là dessus il va vraiment
beaucoup nous manquer mon cas la station
bien sûr alouettes 2 fonteece qu'avec
les images vous dire des tamis mais je
disais tout à l'heure un travailleur un
bosseur quelqu'un de très sérieux dans
ce qu'il faisait dans sa mission pour le
sport et le dernier souvenir et quand il
est venu fermer
l'interview de l'ouverture de la saison
comité cycliste il avait ce cahier bleu
sous le bras ils ouvrent le cahier me
dis comment que tu vas faire pour que le
tour cycliste de la martinique
il y aura la coupe du monde de football
il y aura en même temps le tour cycliste
de martinique car il va falloir que tu
puisses faire comme d'habitude les
gymkhanas voilà c'est ce souvenir vgd
lui et puis mais merci beaucoup monsieur
de fonds 6 9 ans bon vent oui monsieur
voyait donc calé quelle image vous
gardez serait rapidement de camille
alexandre l'image que je garde c'est
toujours celle du jury de la coupe de la
commission qui
pour la nuit des champions où il ya dix
ans il occupait beaucoup de place tant
par la connaissance des sportifs mais
aussi en fait le radio physiquement
merci beaucoup madame moutons vous êtes
le mot de la fin pour une grosse pensée
pour vous son épouse est une femme d'une
grande générosité qui avait accepté de
partager son avis avec le sport et avec
le public et nous allons le garder nous
lui rendons hommage à notre première
compétition est en tout cas je souhaite
que martine et premières puissent garder
camille parce que je pense qu'il a posé
une pierre en ce qui concerne le sport
c'est bien monsieur alain dédé
rapidement un qu'il ya quelques
souvenirs vous gardez justement de deux
cas mais alexandre par rapport à aillot
londres laguiole s'est il donne le
manque énormément l'inimaginable faire
un tour sans lui mes limites je fais les
slogans des deux cas mais c'est
quelqu'un kiev trouver la
complémentarité entre la pratique du
sport
et puis la médiatisation du sport est la
plus belle image c'est l'organisation de
ce que nous appelons la nuit du sport
il a donné cette couleur 7 c'est cette
mare aux sports martiniquais ivan gotti
merci beaucoup et monsieur ben oui pour
le pour le football dernier mot
rapidement petit mot merci beaucoup
alors qu'à me alexandra vue était un
personnage atypique une personnalité
majeure du monde sportif de ces quarante
dernières années et surtout un homme
d'une très grande valeur
il nous manquera à tous je voudrais
remercier tous ceux qui ont collaboré de
près ou de loin à la réalisation de
cette émission merci aux invités merci à
manuel arabe
merci à patrick jean dit oh merci alain
petit le rédacteur en chef
et puis comme dirait camille sportez
vous bien et que votre semaine soit
belle
[Musique]